is coming to its finale manifester left
wondering what is going to happen in
season eight in this video I'm going to
introduce you were a few predictions
that are likely to come true let's start
with first prediction which is a series
of new reunions taking place in the very
first episodes the near sanjana their
entire Cruiser Naboth heading for white
Harbor very David Landon then head to
interval with their arrival many
reunions will take place most
importantly John and Aria we have been
waiting to see the reunion between these
two since the very first season we had
be hoping for a John ah reunion in
season seven but it will just miss the
chatter this is one meeting that has to
happen in the eighth and final season
John loves and cares for all the
siblings but Jan Inara have a unique
bond John an area were very close
growing up it was John who certainly had
needle forged for Arya encouraging her
to become who she always wanted to be
not elated at Westerosi customs demanded
in fact those two were so close that in
George RR Martin's original outline he
had them marked as lovers it's only
fitting for them to see each other again
before the great war begins well it's
easy to say that John will be proud but
also blown away by how much char has
grown as a fighter it's also safe to say
that our evil support John's decision of
bending the knee to the dragon queen I
hope he comes back soon I remember how
happy he was to see me when he says new
his heart will probably stop John and
Sam will all serene hide for the very
first time since John was killed Sam
might or might not know John was killed
and shortly after resurrected since he
was often sending Ravens to him at
Winterfell
but we haven't seen it still together
since season five Sam Vale along with
Bram likely be the one to reveal to John
his sure parentage
since bran is not exactly the best
recently with conversation and handling
emotional conversations all stark
children are reuniting with John Snow
the night Kings conquest begins which
sense for another prediction is likely
to come true the night king hearing the
last heart and karhold in the very first
episode if they breach the wall the
first two castles in their path a last
hearth and car hole
coffe stocks betray that off this is
what John said when he was addressing
the northern Lords in the season 7
premiere which will on the other hand
likely come true in the season 8
premiere those guesses of how somber and
how scarce earth will probably fall
along with their rulers Ned amber and
Ellis Karstark Westerosi people don't
burn their dead which means that the
night king will probably raise thousands
of corpses from the ground we can also
expect to see a familiar face among the
army of the Dead before the end
a white horror would be the most
devastating but it's also possible that
another beloved character dies and is
resurrected in the course of the great
battle let's continue with the
prediction that will most surely come
true which is a huge fight between the
nurses remaining dragons - the night
Kings reanimated dragon once the supreme
leader of the White Walkers place his
hand on Missourians corpse and basically
raised him from death to act as his
minion it became quite certain that the
final season will contain some epic
fights between the dragons this will
most probably eventually result with the
final death of Azarian which might have
been foreshadowed back in the first
season let's first say that the night
king reanimated the corpse of the Fallen
bazarian which makes the ice dragon a
wight that can be destroyed by either
dragon glass or more importantly for
this theory by fire let me also remind
you that vissarion's named that sir
Daenerys is brother Viserys and dragon
on the other hand is named after Dana's
late husband Khal Drogo making the first
season with airs threatened the nearest
which resulted the job of killing him by
dumping melted gold onto his head it's
quite popular theory that Drago named
after Wizards will get his own version
of the golden crown in the last season
by the dragon named after Jogja another
prediction that will almost certainly
come true is Jonathan Ayers learning the
truth about John's lineage the season 7
finale confirmed that John isn't a
bastard but rather Chu born son of
Rhaegar Targaryen and Lyanna Stark whose
name is Aegon Targaryen he is the true
heir to the Iron Throne and more
importantly he is the nurses nephew John
and Danny are heading to Winterfell
verse mo and brain are waiting for John
to final reveal him the truth
it's safe to say that John will finally
reunited brain in the Arya but he will
also find out the shocking truth John
and Danny will without a doubt learn of
their family ties in the season finale
but a bit too late for quite some time
fans have been wondering which house
will John represent once Brennan Sam
revealed to him his sure parentage this
question might have been answered by
John himself in the season finale of
having a conversation with Ian Chen
remark that even though thien's real
father was Balin ed was more of a father
to him than Bale never was
John said you don't need to choose your
Greyjoy and your circ it all need to
choose your a Greyjoy this pretty much
explains the general except the fact
that he's a Targaryen but he will always
be a stark as well the king in the North
might have bent the knee to the dragon
queen but once those two learned the
truth Daniel must surely be the one to
support John's claim to the Iron Throne
learning the truth might not be the only
surprise they'll get early on in season
another surprise and another prediction
is John and Danny having a baby in the
season 7 finale we finally saw the two
who cap well brains voiceover was
explaining that they're in fact related
as we highlighted numerous times during
the season that Danny believes she can
no longer have children because of
prophecy that was told to her by mirror
master it occurred to you she might not
have been her reliable source of
information even though Danny does
believe in this prophecy us Jon Snow
pointed out himself it may not be
entirely true
additionally so many people are talking
about Danny's ability to have children
in so many scenes that it seems like
John and Danny having a baby's not even
questionable but was rather foreshadowed
Tyrion talked to Danny about her plan
for succession then he talked to John
how her dragons are the only children
she'll ever have and even short talk to
John about his future child just as
Justin stated it's highly possible that
the witch was not being honest with
Danny which along with all those
foreshadowings might mean that the
season finale brings more surprising
than we hoped for the only problem is
Danny getting pregnant is another theory
that has been floating around for quite
some time if they initially gets
pregnant could she die in a childbirth
we know that her own mother died giving
birth to her John's mother also died
giving birth to him which puts Danny
pretty dangerous situation let's move on
another prediction which has actually
been confirmed it's the golden company's
arrival MetroCenter conquest over it in
the season finale sirs revealed to Jamie
that you're a Jew only pretended to be
heading back to Pike out of fear when he
had actually sailed to Essos to hire the
golden company and to bring them at his
arm flee to Westeros to serve under
search his commands
this is not coming as a huge surprise
since in the fourth episode of the
season
Cersei revealed her intentions to take
her a new loan from the iron bank too
hard to gun company to expand her armies
is reestablishing control over this
continent and every person on it I see a
great deal of potential in that venture
I imagined it would require outside
investment it will indeed I need to
expand my armies my name is my hand
Qyburn has made overtures to the golden
company in Essos I know them well
they've helped us recover a significant
sums from parties who had fallen into
deeper areas it's good to hear I too
would like them to recover some things
that belong to me
this Seltzer company is one of the
largest and most skilled Merson
organization there is consisting of
20,000 infantry cavalry and war
elephants with their help sir sir will
take the advantage of the war between
the living and the dead and we try to
retreat some things that belong to her
in her opinion those things that Circe
has also revealed herself include the
lands that are currently taken away from
her with the arrival of the golden
company there comes another prediction
which is the return of Darin hearts a
several months ago I brought you a
theory in which dari will reappear in
the last season as a detainee Savior
than his enemy then his last order to
Daario and his cells or company was to
enforce the Queen's peace in the bay of
dragons for a few months until people
choose their rulers the second son's are
known for their loyalty and once they
accept a contract from one side of a
conflict that cannot break it and switch
to the other side since they would be
seen as unreliable and no one would hire
them again
it's almost safe to say that Daario bade
in his orders but what takes place after
that is unknown very fulfilled and his
order sin is now free from any contract
which makes a certain possibility that
he and his company could also be hard to
support sir sis campaign over Westeros
even if Cersei and urine are not taking
the second sons along with the golden
company it's still quite possible that
we might see Daario coming back as
something that in the meantime he became
the leader of the golden company it
would be risky to bring a new character
into Game of Thrones so late in the
series so if he really does get the
golden company to Westeros I think there
is the most likely the candidate for
being their leader this would fade Aria
so sort backstory let's continue with a
prediction regarding the Greyjoy's yours
intentioned become queen of the Iron
Islands was destroyed by her uncle yearn
here was last seen tied to your horse
and being dragged through the streets of
King's Landing all the way to the red
keep upon finding out from your own
dirty are still alive Fiorelli the
remaining Ironborn left in Dragonstone
and formed a rescue party so he could at
least
to savior but will feel managed to even
come close to yar and if he does will he
find your alive already her corpse
remains unknown taking to account that
urine is sailing to Essos with his the
entire island fleet to bring the golden
company to Cersei Theon might manage the
savior if she remain imprisoned on the
Iron Islands however if you are is with
yearn it might lead to another sea
battle in the end the most likely
outcome would be
Theon's arrives with you are being
killed in the process laying Fiona's the
ruler of the Iron Islands another
prediction that is highly possible to
come true is Jon Snow writing Ragle in
the final season the dragon named after
his father after the heartbreaking
battle beyond the wall the nurse only
has two dragons left and since she
writes shogunate would only fit for Jon
the other last living Targaryen to write
Rey go into battle at some point
probably after he learns of his show
parentage a few months ago I made a
video regarding the three-headed dragon
theory that already proved to be quite
accurate so basically that theory
rhaegar targaryen statement in the
nurse's vision the dragon has three
heads means that each of the nearest
street dragons will have their own
riders for all we that are not caught up
with the books are probably wondering
when did bragger say this I'll try to
explain to in a couple of sentences
Danny saw visions in the house of the
undying in both in the books and on the
show but her visions are quite different
in the books than his so no vision of
Jojo and their son but she did see many
other visions so which one was a vision
of her brother Rhaegar saying the dragon
has three heads anyways in that video I
also explained how the three-headed
dragon theory has been foreshadowed as
well as which characters might make up
the three-headed ring of prophecy long
story short who those three dragon
riders might be Danny obviously has an
unbreakable bond with jorgen anne just
some being the last Targaryen beside
Danny would ride the dragon named after
his father Rhaegar but not before the
last season regarding the third dragon
rider that is required to fulfill the
three-headed dragon theory I said that
it would be nice to see Danny John in
Tyrion riding the dragons into battle
against the night king but I also said
that it was kind of too obvious and
simple to be true instead I stated that
the night king will be the third dragon
rider and therefore we would have
Daenerys fired the night King guys and
just no ice and fire riding three
dragons the first part of my theory
already came true in the season 7 finale
leaving the last part of idiot to come
true just now writing Rago in conclusion
six remaining episodes of Game of
Thrones will surely contain huge
surprises twists and some epic battles
between the living and the dead